spear reached record highs in 2020
saudi arabia says it will be carbon
neutral by 2060 and make the move to
hydrogen
and 52 arrests as insulate britain
protests return in the run-up to cop26
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions now the countdown is on it's
less than a week until world leaders
climate change experts scientists and
campaigners all meet in glasgow for the
united nations cop 26 climate summit
it's being hosted by the uk and despite
promising to be global leaders in the
fight against climate change the prime
minister has admitted it could all go
wrong as the one billion dollar pledge
by the world's richest countries is
delayed until 2023
our climate change correspondent hannah
thomas peter reports
hello everyone the prime minister taking
a special downing street press
conference for children an unforgiving
crowd at the best of times particularly
on climate change so honesty the best
policy on the cop 26 u.n climate summit
being hosted in glasgow in a week's time
it could be very very tough
this summit
and i'm very worried because it might go
it might go wrong
and we might not get the agreements that
we need and it's it's touch and go to
help move things in the right direction
the government has made a significant
announcement rich countries have reached
the 100 billion dollar goal of global
climate funding for developing nations
this money was supposed to have been
delivered by 2020 but high-income
nations fell short that's the case for
2021 and 2022.
the next three years up to 2025 are more
positive but for those waiting for the
money being years late is a big deal as
cop 26 president do you accept personal
responsibility for that and any
potential negative consequences for
negotiations at the glasgow summit we
are seeing progress through this
delivery plan i think this is the the
most transparent uh set of forecasts uh
of this nature that we've ever had but
of course countries will need to deliver
on this uh and secondly there is more to
be done
for climate vulnerable countries money
for adapting to the changes that are
already here is the key issue a matter
for many of survival our lives are on
the line we are on the front lines
eighty percent of our population across
the region
are
in low-lying coastal areas and if we
don't have the money to to
adapt to the changes that are already
taking place this isn't uh an academic
issue for us whatever the concerns this
new funding is being pushed as a welcome
positive achievement with cop 26 now so
close and the uk's reputation as a
climate leader on the line the prime
minister is in real need of momentum now
the climate finance announcement will
help with that but there are still some
big problems that need sorting out like
agreement on phasing out coal agreement
on global carbon markets and getting big
polluters to be more ambitious in
tackling global warming
in just a week world leaders will
descend on glasgow and time is ticking
away as the summit by the prime
minister's own admission
hangs in the balance hannah thomas peter
sky news in westminster
well saudi arabia is the latest country
to make its climate pledge today the
crown prince says his country will be
carbon neutral by 2060 in an exclusive
interview with our middle east
correspondent aleister bunkel the saudi
energy minister said the country will
still be a competitive player in the
energy market
saudi arabia is the world's largest oil
exporter and one of the world's biggest
polluters
if cop 26 is going to be a success it
needs countries like saudi arabia on
board
and if saudi arabia wants to protect its
future it needs to change its ways
the saudi economy and saudis themselves
have grown rich off the back of oil
riyad these days is a city of fast cars
glass towers
and luxury shops
is still strictly islamic in many ways
but it is increasingly liberal too
oil has bought saudi arabia regional
power
and global influence
and so if the country moves away from
oil which well ultimately they must
then saudi arabia's position as a major
player in the middle east
could be at risk
at a conference in riyadh senior
government ministers have been
discussing the future
[Music]
it has the backing of the crown prince
mohammed bin salman
it is the usual showcase of technical
revolutions supported by grand promises
that will land well in western capitals
saudi arabia's energy minister half
brother of the crown prince and one of
the country's most senior politicians
insists they can deliver
your power
and your influence globally and
regionally
has come
about as a result of the vast
wells of oil that you have if you move
away from that
potentially you might see that others
will compete for influence around the
world no we're not moving away from that
as opposed to
diversifying
with that
so we will be
you know i call ourselves now that we'll
be transforming ourselves to an energy
country
why
because we have reasons to believe that
we are there
we believe that we will continue to be
competitive
we believe that we could produce
hydrogen and again we will be the
cheapest producer of hydrogen
saudi arabia is having its hand forced
no doubt the world is moving away from
oil whether they like it or not say are
we in a position now is the world in
position where at some point in the
future you can see the end of oil
oil and gas will continue to be part of
the energy mix for decades that doesn't
mean
they will not be they will be the same
they will be cleaner
this is unusual in saudi arabia the
younger generation being asked and
giving their opinion
really we see hope you could see at the
end of the tunnel and as a youth as a
saudi youth i'm really proud that we're
going through that you see movements you
see youth being engaged
being empowered you do not change an
entire culture an entire
state built on energy in one day or
overnight everyone used to think that
our generation is all about oil and
money that's all that's definitely not
the case we definitely think more
greener we think more leadership we
think more innovation
saudi arabia's record on human rights
hangs over this country so too it's
involvement in the yemen conflict
but if they can get their climate
initiatives right
and to make good on their ambitious
promises the country's international
reputation will be the better for it
alice debunking sky news riyad in saudi
arabia
now china has also announced the details
of its plans to reduce emissions over
the next few decades but has failed to
make any new or more ambitious pledges
ahead of cop 26. now china says fossil
fuels will form less than 20 percent of
its energy mix by 2016.
insulate britain has made a comeback
today blocking major roads across london
52 protesters have been arrested with
injunctions granted by the high court
meaning they could be landed with hefty
fines or even a prison sentence the
group is calling for the government to
insulate all homes in the uk by 2030 to
cut carbon emissions
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere once
again reached a new record last year the
world meteorological organization said
the temperate decline during the
pandemic did not have a lasting impact
on atmospheric levels with co2 reaching
149
above pre-industrial levels
we cannot wait uh otherwise we will lose
lose the paris uh paris targets and
and we would suffer
for for for the coming hundreds or even
thousands of years
because of uh high level of carbon
dioxide
well let's have a look at some of those
global emissions on our data dashboard
and this is where we are with co2
emissions and you can see it's clicking
up really all the time and that impacts
this number that's the global
temperature which is currently as you
can see just above 1.2 degrees with 1.5
degrees seen as that point of no return
well let's return now to cop 26 being
held in glasgow this weekend and with
the world watching scotland's first
minister nicolas surgeon has been
wasting no time ensuring the country is
taking a tough stance on climate change
we aim to reach net zero and therefore
completely end scotland's contribution
to climate change by 2045 at the latest
our targets are
not just amongst the most ambitious
anywhere in the world they are also
amongst the toughest
well preparations are underway in
glasgow to get ready for the thousands
of people traveling by train and even
walking or cycling to scotland for the
event
james matthews reports
they've been in training
prop 26 for the cops involved is seen as
one of the most complex and challenging
ever for a uk force
on the banks of the river clyde and the
cloud itself police are preparing for
protests
your entry point and the policing of the
operation by its tone and style is very
much about protection of human rights
about facilitating people's right to
peaceful assembly and peaceful protest
but you prepare for the worst
when motorway escorts do it for real
next week they'll do it for over a
hundred world leaders over hundreds of
miles
all roads lead to the site of the
conference around the scottish
exhibition center a piece of glasgow
that belongs to the un for the duration
[Music]
there will be voices heard inside and
outside the conference venue among them
this group of pilgrims walking 500 miles
from london to glasgow it's the most
important conference climate conference
of my lifetime
this is a crisis for humanity climate
change i think it shows the depth of our
commitment
that we were prepared to walk 500 miles
we need to put pressure on governments
to do the things that they need to do
world attention on scotland shores
concentrates mines in scotland itself
like at this trune primary
here world leaders are in their sights
climate change is on their minds we
would have to stay
away from the beach and change schools
i've put up posters by all the sinks in
our school saying turn off the taps more
houses should have solar panels we
affect it by lowering the prices of
electric cars so normal everyday
families can buy one i think if we act
now and we act fast and
there won't be much left to worry about
cop 26 is all about action
and action stations
james matthews sky news glasgow
well do stay with us because coming up
after the break we're going to be
talking about the differing climate
change pledges around the world as well
as how now record-breaking fuel prices
could shape climate policy in the future
i'm going to be joined by the acting
director of the energy and climate
intelligence unit cephe golzari monroe
and extinction rebellion activist and
co-founder of the cop 26 climate action
plan chidioti obihara
[Music]
there's a treatment for ms called hsct
it's the same treatment that selma blair
had recently
and i've had ms for
10 plus years but in the last couple of
years i noticed it was getting a lot
worse
ms is multiple sclerosis and it's a
disease and illness which stops the
neurological pathways from going from
your brain to different parts of your
body so it stops the signal going there
so it's very debilitating and everyone
has ms in a different kind of way
um i looked into having hsct done in the
uk
and it's impossible unless you go
privately and it is just so ridiculously
expensive
in this country to have it done so i
took the option to fly to mexico to have
the treatment done because mexico and
russia are the leaders in this treatment
so although
mexico have been doing it for 10 15
years
they don't know the full outcome but for
me it has an 80 chance of working and
it's
saves me having to take drugs for the
rest of my life if this works then my ms
will be halted i will stay where i am
now which is still mobile and still
slight cognitively
able
not always but um it will mean that my
ms won't get any worse and i just really
want to try and raise awareness for this
to try and also get neurologists in this
country to know a little bit more about
it so that they when people who are
living with ms like me go in to see
their neurologist they don't feel like
they're just getting completely pooed
about something that is such a brilliant
um hopefully life-changing treatment
the drugs that are given to us in the uk
which is amazing i don't want to be
against drugs because they work so
brilliantly for so many people um but
there is another thing that is
groundbreaking and it's actually much
cheaper for the nhs than the drugs that
people are living on so the drugs that
are offered to you
are brilliant and work for some people
but they can cost sixty thousand pounds
a year whereas people living with ms
could have this treatment done and it
only costs the nhs forty thousand pounds
for the treatment and they may never
have to take drugs again
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to the daily climate
show on sky news and we're getting
straight into discussing the climate
issues of the day with acting director
of the energy and climate intelligence
unit sepi golzari monroe and extinction
rebellion activist and co-founder of the
cop 26 climate action plan chidi oti
obihara good to see you both and of
course one of the big issues of these
climate pledges china announcing details
of its emission reduction plan saudi
arabia saying it's going to
go net zero by 2060 but i mean seppi is
this really too little too late we're
talking decades in the future
thanks steven i'd say honestly it's
never too late every fraction of a
degree matters as the science tells us
and you know as a former diplomat has
put it this is not a cup final we're not
looking for someone to come out of these
talks to wave a piece of paper and say
we've solved climate change these talks
are there to generate the political
pressure for action and to a degree you
know it's working the fact that saudi
arabia the the world's largest oil
producer that spent the best part of a
few decades undermining the climate
process now feels enough political
pressure to come to the table on net
zero that's progress yeah i mean there
are some positive signs today but even
boris johnson has said today it is very
very far from clear that we will get the
progress we need
thank you that's a valid point for boris
to make there are no insurance policies
to make sure we get exactly what we want
however the fact that the saudis who are
building nom you know a solar city
supposed to be competed by 2035 back at
the saudis who have the 600 million ton
per random co2 carbon footprint the fact
that the saudis who would
determined absolutely to maintain the
fossil fuel era for as long as they
possibly could
are now uh pledging that they will
actually get to a point by 2030 where
they cut their methane output by 30
where they they draw out a plan
so that by 2060 they are net zero
all of these are great starting points
for us to continue to talk to the saudis
and just as a minor aside
while we've watched global politicians
dance around the issue of net zero i
think that
prince charles's position of being able
to convince an alternative monarchy in
the middle east with its challenges to
actually change its course
from backing its national uh uh industry
champion aramco to turning around and
saying that they will look at
alternative diversification their
economy i think these are wins i think
this is to be celebrated okay but i mean
what always strikes me with all of this
sepia so you you you both pointed out
the other good steps forward that are
being made but there is always a there's
a lot of rhetoric involved here and the
action is always much slower in coming
and when even the the one billion pound
pledge that was meant to be you know
beginning to be met last year has now
been pushed back to 2023
the action never follows the rhetoric as
quickly as we want it to does it
certainly not as quickly as the science
says it should and that's a fact you
know developed countries have had 12
years to come up with this 100 billion
per year and you know whilst uh they
suggest that they'll be able to meet it
from 2023
and average uh you know 100 billion over
the next five years it's yet to see
whether that will be enough for
developing countries
it's interesting in all of this epic
with uh chad with all the the the
problems that arise when we look at the
international commitments through all of
this uh the secretary general um
said that you know the the needed
changes are economically affordable and
technically possible there is no time to
lose now
when we hear those sort of words
to say it is technically possible and
economically viable
that leaves us with very little excuse
we need to put much more pressure on
somehow don't we
100
i mean to even narrow it more firmly the
u.n second general called this a code
red year after the ipcc's wg um
one report came out just a couple of
weeks a couple months ago we know for a
fact that there is a capacity in
countries across the oecd to make very
rapid changes to decarbonize very
quickly what we're seeing is that there
are obvious roadblocks to change that
happen at national government level
which is why this particular year where
we have co-op 26 coming to britain and
this particular year where local uh city
level uh initiatives are starting this
is a year where real change can be made
and this is a year where if we do pay
attention even after cop at cop27 if we
have to we can carry on putting pressure
on governments at local and activist
levels in a way to remind them of their
their obligations and their duty of care
they have was their citizens okay we're
talking of change actually petrol prices
have hit a record high up 28 pence a
liter in the last year now that i mean
guys i mean that sounds pretty bad for
the motorist and we all need to get
about but is there a positive in all of
this is this going to push people away
from from fossil fuels and onto electric
vehicles perhaps more quickly sepi what
do you think
the first thing i'd say on this is that
it's yet another blow in the rising cost
of living being experienced by the uk
public and it comes really quickly off
the back of this year's gas price hike
seeing wholesale gas prices at record
highs and you know we have to look at
what you know these things have in
common and again it's highlighting the
fact that british public and industries
are vulnerable to these volatile and
increasingly expensive fossil fuels
so it does highlight the urgency to help
the public transition away from fossil
fuels and one positive uh announcement
in that regard was actually last week's
net zero strategy where the government
announced a zero emissions vehicle
mandate uh which is requiring
manufacturers to sell an increasing
percentage of zero emissions vehicles
each year possibly from 2024 and that
will help actually drive down the cost
of reduction sooner
so that
ordinary households can afford them just
a quick point on that is actually we're
looking at evs being cheaper to buy than
petrol and diesel in about five years
time and that's purely through
plummeting tech and manufacturing costs
yeah and that is going to be important
because there's a big price gap at the
moment is isn't that chilly but this
this new survey says 24 of people buying
a new car in the next year so they
intend to buy electric or hybrid perhaps
you could say it's not enough but i mean
it's a big chunk of people
it is and the policy that stops new
diesel cars being sold in 2030 is is a
really important policy what we realize
from sort of the academic studies is
that the price elasticity of petrol uh
isn't that high in the short term so
when the price of petrol goes up people
can't quickly and immediately switch
they need more important structural
things like encouragement of the
government to fund a good class uh
scrappage scheme and to enable electric
and hybrid vehicles to become governing
smart streets so of course today in
london is the launch of the ulis scheme
which uh mayor khan has has as a
slikhaan has has lauded as a good way of
getting a lot of diesel and petrol cars
off the road and we we very firmly
support that the one thing i would add
is that when you look at the the
marketplace as it exists now we're
looking at the way that all fossil fuels
across the energy value chain impact
everyone it isn't just motorists it's
also utility companies that are
suffering terrible damage from increa
increasingly volatile oil and gas
markets so transition for the public is
not just about transport it's about
energy as a whole it's about our
utilities it's about transport it's
about our manufacturing it's about
reorganizing society in a way that makes
things better for everyone we're we're
out of time but chilly sepi good to see
you both thank you
do stay with us more coming up
[Music]
you